well we'll have the FBI has been busy
raiding the president's lawyer's office
to find stormy Daniels documents our
next guest is spearheading the effort to
find out why the Department of Justice
open the Russian collusion probe in the
first place
surprise surprise the DOJ won't give us
straight answers
joining me now exclusively House Intel
committee chairman Devin Nunez a
Republican from California Congressman
Nunez thanks for being on tonight it's
great to be here you've been trying to
get documents for as long as I've been
doing this show all your documents and
people have been asking why is it that
you haven't yet held anyone in contempt
of Congress that's a big deal to do that
you know Eric Holder was held in
contempt of Congress as I recall over
the Fast and Furious documents but what
gives here well you've been in a
situation where it's trickled down
documents so we issued the subpoena in
August we walked through piece by piece
every time we get a little bit more as
you know we had to get out the major
information which was the information on
the warrant against Carter page we got
trump associate so since that time we've
been investigating the State Department
and we have a especially have an
interest in this electronic
communication EC that never cease e
which is the document that establishes
the justification correct for ultimately
naming the special counsel this whole
thing ended up in the especially on the
open the counterintelligence
investigation the counter-intel
initially that ultimately led to the
special
yeah so it's a two-page document I sent
chairman Gowdy over there to see it
originally it was fully redacted so they
couldn't read anything I called back
several times had conversations with rod
Rosenstein and with director ray the FBI
director mr. Gowdy and the investigators
went over there again and there was only
a few more things that were unredacted
so most of it was still redacted so now
we're at this point again we're at a
boiling point where we need this what is
only a two-page document
it's only a two-page it's less than two
pages from what I understand and you
know if if the record wasn't that every
time they hide something from us that
then we find out it was really bad and
they
from us for a like a judge contrary
issue like this like the text like the
page down information
unredacted oh no that's why you were
dead that's right now just the fact that
they're not giving this to us tells me
there's something wrong here
well Bob cost Roberto Costa from the
Washington Post is speculating tonight
on Twitter that you are on the verge of
moving to hold Christopher Rea and rod
Rosenstein in contempt of Congress and
you have a deadline of tomorrow
apparently to get this information is
this like a possibility I can tell you
this we are going to get the document we
are going to get the two pages so they
can either cough them up now or it will
get really complicated starting tomorrow
night and we'll have to take all the
steps necessary in order to get the
documents what do you what are you
thinking might be in this document I
mean is are you going to intent intent
well we have a policy if Trump were
actually the nominee or the or the
ultimate Victor well here's our
challenge with this so if you believe
what's in the New York Times in
washington post's so sometimes they
actually do get leaked information so
getting a lot lately in that leaked
information that came out in December
December 30th I think of this year was
the information on an Australian
diplomat talking to mr. Papadopoulos
that's what they say is in the EC but we
haven't been able to see the EC to
confirm that so somehow the New York
Times has it the American people have
read it but the US Congress does not
have that information and we we deserve
we have the full right to that
information you disturbed by some of
these leaks that seem to be emanating
from the special counsel's office or
from the US Attorney's Office Southern
District of New York about the the the
intent of what that raid on the Cohen
office was what they were really looking
for what they were what they're
speculating
seems like a lot of information came out
yesterday it last 20 well the bigger
problem we have about the leaks and I'll
say this for the 100th time the special
counsel I would have thought would have
got to the felony leaks of general
Flynn's name being leaked to the press
with very very high-level information
and so it seems like the Special Counsel
is good at leaking but not so good at
actually finding major felony leak
what are the chance you're gonna hold
them in contempt of Congress right now
well I could just tell you that we're
not going to just hold in contempt we
will have a plan to holding can tip and
to impeach to impeach Christopher Rea
absolutely rod Rhodes we're not we're
not messing around here they're going to
give these two they're gonna say you're
just Trump's Lackey here you're doing
Trump's bidding that's what the
Democrats they've been demonizing you
from the beginning I've been the
subjects of demonization myself so I
know how it goes but they're gonna
demonize you and say oh you're gonna run
over the White House help Trump out
every time you he needs he's in a jam
yeah well as I said before whenever I
see evidence of Russian collusion I'll
be the first person standing out there
in the steps of the Capitol that I found
look at Russian collusion with the Trump
campaign I haven't found it yet but I
found a whole lot of other stuff that
always puts DOJ and FBI in a bad light
unfortunately the media other other
media channels are salivating tonight in
a frothy frenzy over once again Trump's
gonna fire robert muller trump's gonna
fire robert muller Huckabee sanders was
asked about this today this is what she
said uber special counsel only he has
the power to fire again we've been
advised that the president certainly has
the power to make that decision I don't
think there's any sign that Trump's
really gonna fire Muller but you know
Republicans are freaking out about that
as well but yeah it's said this before
yeah he was firing all kinds of people
and none of that ever came to fruition
Preet Bharara the former US Attorney
Southern District of New you go get
fired he did get fired by President
Trump still very angry about this this
what he said today the regulation is
very clear with respect to the special
counsel it says the special counsel may
be disciplined to remove from office
only by the personal action of the
Attorney General and you may remove the
special counsel for a number of
enumerated reasons including misconduct
dereliction of duty dereliction of duty
incapacity and some other things and has
to provide those reasons in writing so
it's very clear that if the president
United States call under the current
circumstances and as long as these
regulations are in effect called up by
Muller and said I'm firing you Bob
Muller I would expect would not heed
that apparently the regulations Trump
the Constitution we have an executive
annc judicial branch legislative branch
in which branch does Bob Muller reside
the executive branch yes because I mean
again it I think it would not be smart
at all for the president to fire Bob
Muller I do not think it makes sense
it's tempting as it may be I don't think
it makes sense but the idea that did he
doesn't the constitutional authority to
do that whether it's politically smart
I mean Primera was US Attorney I do what
you want me reaction to that well it
shows you how this is how far we've gone
down over the last eight or nine years
where the courts have become activist
courts activist judges the fact that DOJ
and FBI think that they're above the law
so Congress the legislative branch we
created these agencies and they have a
responsibility to give us documents when
we ask for them we have the appropriate
clearances that's why the House
Intelligence Committee exists so you
know at the end of the day we're gonna
win on this and it's just a matter of
how tough they're gonna make it for
Congress to actually do our job that we
under the Constitution than the
priorities that we're given what to hold
someone in contempt of Congress I don't
know the the process you're the head of
the Intel committee do you need to have
sign-off from others in the Intel
committee again there's a lot of
different ways you could do it right
quick well we're doing now is that
ultimately the Congress has to vote on
it
okay so it's not for quick yeah well you
think what's the chances of that well I
don't think we're gonna have to get
there because I think they're gonna give
us the documents we are gonna follow
this then we're gonna check up on it
tomorrow April 11th is a deadline so
tomorrow all right well thank you so
much congressman thank you